there was an announcement today by the
Food and Drug Administration Bettina
Gregory has the story
today the Food and Drug Administration
approved what it caused the first
significant drug to stop women from
going into labor too soon it's called
ritadrine hydrochloride but it's known
generically as read a dream a warning
today to pregnant women about the
possible dangers in coffee tea and colas
the Food and Drug Administration says
the caffeine in those drinks has caused
birth defects in laboratory animals and
that until human testing is more
conclusive expectant mothers should try
to avoid beverages with caffeine another
health-related matter the FDA today took
its first step in putting the and
putting into action the infant formula
Act of 1980.
the Food and Drug Administration today
often in the news and back around the
turn of the century unsafe foods and
drugs were also in the news and that's
how FDA came to be I'm Paul Berry with
the FDA story a Chronicle of Science and
law working together to protect the Food
and Drug supply of the American Consumer
[Music]
thank you
the range of FDA activities today the
scale and complexity of its
responsibilities contrast sharply with
fda's maker beginning at the turn of the
century resources were limited staff few
in number Authority almost non-existent
but the Food and Drug Administration
back then had an invaluable asset a
truly remarkable man who helped shape
its Destiny Dr Harvey Washington Wiley
I met Dr Wily at an aoac meeting in 1928
it was quite a thrill to me as a young
chemist to have seen and heard Dr Wily
the
father of the Food and Drugs Act of
1906. Dr Wily came to the Bureau of
chemistry from Purdue University where
he had been professor of chemistry he
also had served the state of Indiana as
a chemist during that same period in
their agricultural Department
uh he'd he was a native of the state of
Indiana I believe and had some Farm
experience
and certainly was interested in
agriculture and at the Bureau of
chemistry engaged in research projects
involving agriculture
he was a physician he had a medical
degree I do not know whether he had
practiced medicine most of his work had
been in chemistry at the University and
in the state and of course later in the
federal government
in the 20 years that Dr Wiley and his
supporters fought for Federal Regulation
of foods and drugs they exposed
conditions that in some respects were so
horrendous they seem almost unbelievable
today Foods were commonly mixed with
harmful fillers and preservatives the
lack of Sanitation caused milk to become
a common carrier of communicable
diseases medications containing
narcotics were sold freely addicting the
unwary and causing numerous deaths
quackery flourished worthless
medications were sold on the promise
they'd cure virtually every disease
Dr Wiley called for legislation that
would curb these harmful practices and
he urged influential groups to join in
his campaign
strong support came from food industry
leaders who were facing both dishonest
competition and intolerable variations
in state laws
in 1903 Dr Wiley captured the attention
of the nation when he established a
volunteer Squad of young men who agreed
to eat food treated with suspect
chemical preservatives
Riley decided to set up what he called a
hygienic table in the basements basement
of the Bureau of chemistry building
and to select a group of young men
12 he chose mostly from the workers in
the Department of Agriculture and his
bureau of chemistry some from outside
and have them eat food
only at that table Wiley himself I might
say ate most of his meals with these
young men
Wiley
studied their health as they went
through a diet that had added to it one
of these preservatives
but newspaper reporters learned about it
and it was a Washington Post reporter
who coined the phrase poison Squad and
gave rather too much Sensational
publicity as Wiley thought to the whole
affair
crusading journalist joined in the
campaign helping to arouse public Ira by
publishing cartoons articles and
editorials
opinion reached fever pitch when a
chapter in Upton Sinclair's novel The
Jungle exposed the terrible conditions
in the Chicago Stockyards foreign
[Music]
public concern prompted Congress to pass
both a Meat Inspection law and the Food
and Drugs act both bills were signed
into law by President Theodore Roosevelt
on the last day of June 1906.
the Food and Drug Act prohibited
interstate commerce and adulterated and
misbranded foods and drugs products that
violated the law could be seized and
destroyed
Dr Wiley resigned in 1912.
his successor was Dr Carl Ellsberg
continuing under Ellsberg as Chief
Inspector and succeeding him was a man
who would influence the agency's history
for four decades Walter G Campbell
in the early 1930s Campbell pressed for
revisions in the 1906 law to correct
some serious shortcomings Campbell
showed Congress a series of posters
depicting hazardous products that were
sold freely under the existing law there
were pictures of a woman whose eyeballs
had been corroded by an aniline eyelash
dye a man who died from a radium water
product
quack devices risky reducing products
and a stack of death notices testifying
to the failure of a horse fundament sold
to people as a cure for tuberculosis
the posters were put together with
products and devices and a dramatic
exhibit that became known as the
American Chamber of Horrors but it took
a nationwide tragedy to change the law
the crisis emerged in the form of a
product that started out as a boom for
many people
it was called sulfonylamide and its
infection fighting properties made
headlines when sulfonylamide pills saved
the life of FDR's son but later a small
pharmaceutical firm rushed a liquid form
of a drug to the market without testing
it for safety the liquid form contained
the solvent diethylene glycol which is
now used in brake fluid and antifreeze
disaster struck headlines the country
over broke the news of a mounting death
toll caused by the solvent and elixir
sulfamilamide that tragedies pointed to
the need for a new law ensuring the
safety of drugs before marketing
in 1938 Congress passed the federal Food
Drug and cosmetic to act President
Roosevelt signed the new law on June
25th 1938.
I came to the agency in 1939 just about
the time the 1938 Act was taking effect
what it did was make
improvements in all areas drugs Foods
Cosmetics devices and so forth new drugs
were required to be proven safe before
they could be marketed avoidable
unnecessary poisons were banned from
food and those that were unavoidable or
necessary in production were required to
be controlled under safe tolerances food
sanitation Food and Drug labeling were
improved remarked extensively economic
concerns were addressed through
standards of identity
quality and fill a container for Foods
cosmetics and medical devices were
brought under control for the first time
and enforcement was improved by
Authority for factory inspection by
Grant of jurisdiction for court
injunctions by increased criminal
penalties and extension of the seizure
Authority all of this made for much
better Public Law
Pearl Harbor catapulted our nation into
World War II
the FDA staff that was stretched then
before the war had to take on a massive
drug testing job created by the new law
enforcement of the law went on and some
important victories were tallied
an anti-obesity product called marmola
which consisted of ground-up animal
thyroid glands was finally taken off the
market after 30 years of litigation
quack diabetes remedies were removed
from the market their promoters fined
and jailed after vigorous prosecution
war was also waged by FDA with varying
degrees of success against quack Canter
cures and clinics that delivered nothing
except transient hope
the discovery and widespread use of
penicillin on the battlefields of World
War II brought more new legislation
requiring certification of the safety
and efficacy of every batch
later Congress extended this requirement
to all antibiotics
new responsibilities were legislated to
FDA after the war as food technology
made great advances with the use of
chemicals
in 1954 FDA was given authority to
enforce tolerance levels for pesticide
residues of possible harmful substances
remaining in food after harvesting in
1958 the agency was given authority to
require manufacturers to prove the
safety of food additives
in late 1959 senator keifah of Tennessee
began investigating drug pricing in
testimony it became clear that other
problems needed consideration as well
for one thing there were inadequate
controls over the distribution and use
of drugs for testing legislation was
drafted to correct these flaws but it
might never have been enacted had it not
been for another disaster the
application for thalidomide was
submitted to FDA in September 1960. I
was a medical officer signed to review
it and it was also reviewed by a
pharmacologist and a chemist we felt the
data was insufficient to support safety
and requested further information
while this was being assembled we
learned of that peripheral neuritis was
associated with the use prolonged use of
the drug in countries where it had been
approved for marketing
we asked for further data both regarding
this and possible safety in pregnancy
we asked this because at that time there
was a developing interest in Awareness
that the fetus and embryo and the
newborn did not always respond to drugs
as did the adult
the answer came swiftly and conclusively
headlines all over the world reported
thousands of cases in Western Europe of
malformed babies born to women who had
taken the drug thalidomide the drug
company withdrew its new drug
application from FDA but they ate the
little my disaster though avoided in
this country stirred strong public
reaction and moved Congress to act
the 1962 amendments to the food drug and
cosmetic act added the requirement that
drugs had to be effective before they
could be approved and also added other
requirements to strengthen the drug law
the Amendment added a new realm of
responsibility for the agency
during the decade of the 70s there was
tremendous growth in the agency it no
longer regulated Just Foods drugs
cosmetics and devices in 1971 the agency
was assigned their responsibility for
setting and regulating safety standards
for products and equipment that emit
radiation
in 1972 the division of biologics was
transferred to FDA from the National
Institutes of Health The Authority for
assuring the safety Effectiveness Purity
and proper labeling of biologic such as
serums and vaccines and for overseeing
blood bank operations
with the advances of healthcare
technology that employed medical devices
such as heart pacemakers and artificial
limbs new medical device legislation
became necessary it was provided in 1976
when Congress gave FDA the authority to
regulate medical devices and ensure
their safety and effectiveness as a
result life-supporting and implanted
devices must be tested before they can
be sold
the responsibilities Congress placed on
FDA in the 70s brought FDA staff to 7500
employees even with the dramatic growth
in staff and budget enforcement of the
increasing statutory responsibilities
has been an awesome task
in the food area alone there are 79 000
establishments under fda's jurisdiction
[Music]
investigators inspect an average of 30
000 establishments annually
[Music]
we have 47 investigators in the
Baltimore district and there are six
thousand establishments under our
jurisdiction
FDA scientists analyze approximately 27
000 domestic and 17
000 foreign products each year
in the Baltimore District laboratory we
have 28 scientists who analyze product
samples develop methods of analysis and
do research
the routine work is taxing enough but
when an emergency develops sheer
dedication gets the job done
when the nuclear incident at Three Mile
Island occurred FDA people worked Around
the Clock advising local officials
collecting and analyzing samples of food
for possible radiation contamination and
providing pharmaceutical antidotes
when dangerous substances such as pcbs
get into the food supply the lights burn
all night at FDA
a PC Beast bill from one electric
Transformer sent FDA investigators to
1400 firms in 19 States they were there
to see that none of thousands of
contaminated chickens and turkeys ever
reached the marketplace
how well FDA does its job is tested in
that Marketplace Americans can shop with
a high degree of confidence because our
country's Foods drugs medical devices
biologics animal drugs and feeds and
radiological products are the safest in
the world but conditions change new
challenges arise
more than three quarters of a century
ago when the first Food and Drug law was
put into effect the main Public Health
concern was about the harmful substances
that were deliberately packed into foods
and medicines today the concern is more
likely for substances that end up into
products by chance that have to be
detected in parts per billion that
remain in the Buddy for years waiting to
upset cellular mechanisms and cause
cancer
well we've literally had a revolution in
this country in the past 75 years in our
ability to promote Health Care through
better nutrition and and better care
and in my judgment there's every reason
to believe that the future holds even
more dramatic gains over in every field
over which FDA has has responsibility
I think they're going to be enormous
challenges in everything we do the
challenge to make sure that the benefits
of technology which is going to be
advancing all the time
outweighs the risks the challenge to
nurture innovation
without jeopardizing the public health
and most important the challenge to give
the people of this country confidence in
the products that they use and in the
ability of the FDA to make sure those
products are reliable
the work has been difficult in the past
it's going to be even more difficult in
the in the years ahead but that's what
makes our work so vital so challenging
and to me very very exciting
the Food and Drug Administration three
quarters of a century-old but still full
of Youth this has been the FDA story
laughs